I hope this letter finds you well.
I was looking at some pictures yesterday and it made me think of you.
We've had a wonderful seven years together.
It has been an honor to have called you a teammate for 13 years.
I'm grateful for your love and support and I know you have my back.
I feel like we've had a special bond.
It has been a privilege to watch you play over your career...
...and I'm honored to call you a friend.
You did it the right way.
And I knew that you loved to win and hated to lose with the same passion as me.
You know I've always looked up to you.
To play as long as you did and at such a high level is incredible.
You've taught me a lot.
I have great respect for your work ethic and "team first" attitude.
It wasn't always easy.
Some things you just can't control.
It's okay.
You're the best teammate I could ever ask for.
It was an honor to play with you in Indy and again in Denver,...
...to be Broncos together,...
...brothers.
It's been a great ride.
Keep grinding.
I wish you all the best in the next chapter of your life.
Congratulations again.
Tell the family hello.
Love you, pal.
I'm proud of you.
Sincerely.